hey everyone it's Mike Votto's and
welcome to the order flows market
analysis for September 7 2017 it's
actually mid sessions around times it's
around 11:00 a.m. Chicago time I'm
recording this one a bit early I didn't
get one out yesterday but you know
there's some interesting things this
morning that you know I didn't have the
trading room this week I'm just a little
bit caught up with some other stuff but
you know I I do want to talk about a few
interesting things this morning and in
some of these markets so brief
disclaimer this is presentation is for
educational informational purposes only
should not be considered a solicitation
to buy or sell a futures contract or
make any other type of investment
decision futures train contain
substantial risk and is not for every
investor an investor could potentially
lose all or more than the initial
investment risk capital is money that
can be lost without jeopardizing one's
financial security or lifestyle only
risk capital should be used for trading
and only those were sufficient risk
capital should consider trading past
reports it's not necessarily indicative
of future results
okay the tools used in this presentation
are the same as always the order flows
trader a volume footprint chart and the
Delta scalper I may talk about a couple
other indicators if when you see them in
there but the main ones that I use in my
trading right now are the order flows
trader and the Delta scalper at mean I
could I have other indicators that I use
but you don't want to get too confusing
for people especially those that are
relatively new to order flow and are
trying to learn it you know keep it
simple learn a few things you know
there's a lot of different aspects of
order flow and if you try to learn
everything at once you're just gonna in
the end confuse yourself and it's kind
of pointless so stick to you know a few
things with order flow and go from there
build from there so bonds this morning
we're quite interesting you know go back
to you know the heights you had earlier
at 5:52 is very slow morning actually
coming into the session you know from
basically from midnight until 5:30 you
got we got one bar and finally you hit
this new high here you got divergence
you don't have a bullish or show you
don't have a bearish ratio you have a
delta scalper kicking off though giving
you an a sell signal next bar it comes
back up a little bit you got you know
you've got you know multiple three
imbalances in there
but again its its market at this point
is really doing nothing even taking the
cell signal here I think is a it's a bit
of a stretch you know it's mark is just
too quiet at this time to really get too
excited
you really you got a couple of sound
imbalances point of control near the top
you know you got the Delta scalper you
got the divergence you got a few things
going on in there we do come back up
test the high again you got another
divergence then you sell off you get to
this bar this bar is very interesting
here at six fifty four point control
right on the bottom on the extreme
bullish ratio you know a nice positive
Delta I love this bar you know this is
great bar for it's a great buying
opportunity the only thing I would love
about it more if this was on the low of
the day it's it's I don't wanna call us
a swing but you know he did sell off
from the high over the next couple bars
but you know the way the mornings been
since you know since yesterday since
last night you know that's a move in
this market honestly because they're so
so slow um someone made comment please
try not this please no cursing no
profanity somewhere trying keep it clean
if something comes out it's just because
I'm excited you know I don't mean
anything bad by it sometimes I get
excited and I get all caught up in it
you know when I was on the trading floor
you know everyone not on the trading
floor so you know we're like sailors and
you know what I learned was you know
don't cross the line and make it
personal you know when I use profanity
generally it's just as you know
adjectives you know again I don't mean
anything by it and you know I sorry if I
apologize any book to anybody but I'm
sorry if I offended anybody but again I
sometimes I just get excited and you
know when I get excited I tend to sort
of veer off track a bit like Donald
Trump but anyway you rally up from this
swing low order control right on the
bottom very bullish bar get up to the
high divergence no ratio price rejecter
kicking in next bar you got the ratio
and next bar you got another ratio will
start moving lower you got two
imbalances to imbalances you know this
aggressive selling coming in you get
down here
putting control towards the bottom you
know earlier that was that who knows at
18 19 you know down here it gets down to
see some supportive buying
coming in here next bar starts rallying
back up got a bullish ratio you got the
Delta scalper kickin in a nice positive
Delta and what happens next bars up and
then it comes right back down but we
come back down to this twenty level
again you know where where you had
stopped it before again point control
towards the bottom Delta scalper again
giving you a nice signal so you know it
had you taken this one you know maybe
you're stopped out you know it if you're
short from here from this ratio on
divergence you know you this trade
really you probably looking at breakeven
I don't think it'd be you know taking
you're taking a loss up here at I think
it'd be sort of breaking even when it
sort of comes back into this area maybe
losing a tick or so but you know I was
really expecting a bigger move I was
expecting move down to sixteen didn't
happen then here anyway eight twenty
eight six here in this bar here putting
control towards the lower the bar Delta
scalper as well nice positive Delta
eleven hundred they start rallying
rallying rallying you got a high you
have a racial but you don't have a
divergence you know point controls up
near the top so all you have at this
point is a ratio and you know when we
get ratios I do expect pull backs to
those levels so right now there's
there's no major reason to be getting
short there is you know this second this
buying imbalance 1066 which is bearish
actually you know what the market came
right back really quick yeah again if it
was looking to sell off usually you know
this sort of bar you know where you have
the buying imbalance here or selling and
balances on the way down you close lower
is a bullish as a bearish bar to me but
you know hey you know you had this we
call Delta scalper right here so you
know if you're buying it at twenty four
you're looking at this bar and it's kind
of bearish so you know maybe you're
covering it up here at twenty eight
twenty nine so you know you had no
that's giving you five you know five
ticks right there and then you know if
you didn't cover it if you're waiting
for the next Delta sculpt or signal to
come in didn't come in you don't know I
mean when I say the next Delta scalper
signal I mean the next sell signal you
already had to buy at a couple buys this
morning just short of ran into this bar
that's kind of bearish so maybe you
would have lightened up and taken it
then you're missing this major move that
happens in trading you know sometimes
you get out because what the market is
telling you at this point in time is you
know there's a sign in here that you
know the market could sell off I mean
what can you do if you're a trader right
and you see signs or are you looking at
the market at this point okay let's be
honest right I could sit here and say no
you know you can't sell it but this is
something I would normally be looking to
sell this type of bar you know honestly
I'd be looking for a pullback up to the
31 level or then the sell-off so for me
to say yeah you have this buy here and
you'd hold it all the way up to this
move is you know disingenuous you know
that's a term now that I hear all the
time on a news you know Hawaii these
politicians talk is disingenuous so I'm
not gonna say that yeah I would have
bought it here and held it all the way
up you know up up here all the way to
157 you know 20 No you know I've seen
this borrowed I would have gotten out
honestly yeah but you know people said
well your allows you trade or no you
know I've sold these bars many many
times and that's just a very bearish bar
to me so anyway we do rally up he's
getting some nice binding balances here
25 88 1789 you come back up here you got
not a ratio no divergence still positive
Delta still going higher higher higher
right now we're sort of selling off a
bit here we have the divergence you
don't have a ratio again important
controls in these bars sort of in the
middle but what do you got up here you
got negative Delta 9 78 92 309 you know
this is a sign of a market selling off
just by reading the Delta just by seeing
how the deltas forming you know it just
looks like this markets come back down
you know it would have been nice yeah I
admit you know it would have been nice
to say yeah you easily you know you know
yom-yom trade you gotta buy this here
you wouldn't sell it here but honestly
looking at this you would have gotten
out you should have I would have gotten
out here based off this this bar then I
would have missed the full point move
but you know sometimes you that happens
it sucks but you know that's that's the
reality of it you know I don't want to
make you think it's something else when
it's when it's not now five years this
morning
again it's 6:45 you got your high
divergence 7:33 a new high divergence
and a ratio do you sell off not really
you sell off about four or five ticks
rally back up that high you got another
divergence so right now you've got
they're ready you know from six forty
five to eight o'clock you already got
three failed divergences which is a sign
of if we rally start rallying up and
making new highs again that's a sign
that we can go higher right that the
market is pushing higher you know the
trend hasn't really started yet you know
you don't know if it's a going to be a
trend a or an on trend day but right now
you keep bumping up against this highs
you know you got the failed divergence
earlier you got a divergence and
divergence I'm curious as hell to see
I'm sorry curious as heck to see if we
come back up here and take out this high
if we take out this high we could be off
to the races and what do you see right
now you've seen some nice positive
deltas building up three thousand nine
thousand let's just walk it through you
get here 8:24 you got a bearish bar you
got another divergence you've got a
ratio which is bearish but again you
know if you're shorting it you know
you're just looking at a few bars here
earlier that you had ratios you know you
had the divergence one with the ratio on
divergence that didn't really sell off
so now you're looking again at another
ratio and divergence you know it might
sell off it might not we don't know yet
856 next bar it's a bullish ratio comes
right back with the bullish ratio so you
have the bearish ratio you got a bullish
ratio you've got you know the divergence
here so this bar is bearish but you run
right back into a bullish bar and look
at the Delta again 2151 so the Delta is
strong there's good buying coming in
here take out the high three imbalances
as you're taking out the high at this
point again you've got four failed
divergences already in you know not even
two hours that's a sign you know that
five years for you know for the five
years to move you know be making for new
highs in two hours is a big thing
because sometimes you know it's sort of
like a sleeping giant it just sort of
you know named me Anders along but once
it picks up a head of steam and starts
rallying watch out you could get a good
rally here you got a nice another nice
strong Delta for
five hundred get up here another
divergence what's gonna happen
we got a ratio again bearish you know
this one failed but it came right back
you saw the sign right here that is
gonna fail what happens same thing
bullish ratio stack mine imbalance nice
book Delta 3000 so again you know if
you're looking at this bearish ratio and
you're thinking getting short as soon as
you see this bar coming in like this you
you got to get out you don't fight it
you know you got a a bullish very
bullish bar right after you got the
bearish bar don't don't sit here and
think well you know I got this bearish
signal I'm gonna let it either come down
to my profit or stop me out no you get
out early get out you know before it
stops you out save yourself a few ticks
you know there's so what happens boom
new high you got a nice buying a balance
here 6,000 look at the Delta 4500
positive so you know where markets
picking up a head of steam and starting
to go higher here this one's interesting
you get a new high negative Delta
actually but it's an up are it's an up
market close higher than then we're open
why do you have a why do you have a
negative Delta on a bar on a new high
that's markets going higher still you
know you got a green bar that's the
difference between the order flow trader
software and most other wonderful volume
footprint charts is a lot of other
charts would read this as a divergence
which for me is not a divergence why
yeah you have negative Delta at a new
high but you don't have the price
section of the bar you know I'm not
interested in getting short on a bar
that closes higher no you know I want
the bar if I'm going to be looking to
get short I want it you know the bar to
be trading lower I don't be bar still
rallying you know why why would you get
short on a bar that's that's trending
trading up trading higher you know maybe
people say well when you get a better
fill no you don't look to get short a
rally in market unless you have a really
legitimate reason but you know if one of
the reasons why you want to get short is
you think the market is going to come
off but the market is still rallying
what's the point you know it's kind of
no reason anyway you know how can a
market rally on a negative Delta well
when you have supportive bind here you
get 6002
34 that's why you have the negative
Delta because you got very big volume up
here you got a very strong bitter coming
in at this what was at 28 level 118 28
supporting the market okay
next bar we don't even come back down to
that level cuz there's a big buyer down
there again a nice positive Delta 2600 a
nice bullish ratio up here you get up
here you got a new high now you have
another divergence so again you know if
you were buying these breakouts you know
buying breakouts is a tricky proposition
it's not as cut and dry as people think
you know on trending days yeah it's the
greatest trading method out there you
know if it's if the day is gonna be a
trending day but if it's a non trending
day it's probably one of the worst
trading strategies you can have so any
way you could identify that it's a
potential trending day early buying
breakouts is going to help you and one
of the ways you can determine that is
with failed divergences coming you know
in secession and you got it you know so
if you were buying it here right I mean
you had the you had one two three four
failed divergences you could safely I
think you could safely buy this breakout
here one you know and this is how you
want the bracket to breakout you wanted
to break out with aggressive buying with
behind imbalances it would be much
beautiful much more beautiful if it was
a stacked imbalance but you got this one
12:47 gets 1961 so you don't have the
what you call it the ratio to give you
the stack imbalance but all these other
ones you have three imbalances in there
so again it's still it's still important
even though it's not stacked a little
bit later you do get the stacked
imbalance again you got the next
divergence here that you come right back
you got a dresser bind the stacked
imbalance and boom you take out the next
high okay
again you know even if you didn't buy it
here coming back up here you could also
buy it you know what's your risk your
risk is it's not much you're only
talking a few ticks but you know in
trading that's what you want you want to
limit your risks certainly you know keep
going higher keep going higher another
divergence that fails to get up here to
this high you got the bearish ratio
still got positive Delta so you don't
have the how to say it you don't have
the ratio the divergence because you got
the positive Delta but again you know
take a look at the Delta and you know
that's why I like these Delta candles
here you know it's if you joined the
inner circle you get the Delta candles
because it's visual you know I'm a
visual person you know I like Instagram
and things like that um like looking at
pictures but the brain processes image
is much faster than the text right so
yeah you could read the Delta you don't
need to Delta candles but it just makes
it much quicker identification and what
do you got you got very early in this
bar very strong positive Delta 7600 no
he ended up at twenty two thousand two
hundred forty five which is strong don't
get me wrong but to go from 7600 to only
2200 it gave back 5000 you know it gave
back quite a quite a bit of Delta okay
so maybe you're not convinced here you
wait for the next bar a couple of
imbalances 2700 5000 strong negative
Delta minus 3900 so you got your high on
kind of weakening Delta you know it's
kind of hidden in there and that's why I
like order flows because you could see
this information you can see how it's
you know even though it's positive Delta
you could analyze it and know it's
weakening you know pretty easily
next barn all not all but predominantly
negative Delta so predominantly
dominated by sellers you got the stack
that's dead you got the imbalance here
and balance there and you know it's
starting to look bearish and what
happens we continue off over the next
two or three bars you know heading a bit
lower right now okay really quick this
is the e-mini this is the for range
chart and again it was kind of quiet
morning during the European session but
nevertheless we made it low here at 2:57
so you know a little bit earlier 217 you
had a divergence that failed then you
got another divergence but at this time
you got the Delta scalper giving you a
buy signal and it's beautiful why again
you know it's any reason that you could
have to be
buying off aloe or selling off a high
take it you know say you have any sort
of trading setups you know it's a buy
set up and you're trading near the low
take it you know I think you're gonna
get more out of the trade than if you're
taking it in the middle of a range or
you know if you're trading higher just
as you know if you get a cell signal up
near the high take it you know your risk
is gonna be a little bit less I think
and you know you got potential for to go
from your high to your low and keep
going lower so anyway what happens you
got you buy signal here right off the
low and you do rally you rally up to new
highs new highs I mean there's no reason
we can short here you just got a bearish
ratio here it's not the end of the world
but it's coming already
a bar after you're you're getting into
the trade you come up here and start
making new highs up here so you can you
know what's this level when you get the
you know twenty four sixty one sixty one
and a half
what does it do it rallies all the way
up to 65 sorry 66 you got the Delta
scalper giving you a cell here and
there's work it comes right back up hits
the high again got a stack buying and
balance stack society stack selling and
balance right at that same level where
you had right around where you had the
Delta scalper so you getting some
bearish signs up here actually you know
you've you've got divergences one two
you got less volume the second time you
come up there you got the Delta scalper
you've got stacked selling and balance
and what happens unfortunately the
market just goes sideways on you that
sucks
and again you know with these stacked
imbalances you know the reason why I
draw these levels out you know this red
area five levels if I know that if by
the third fourth level if we're still
hanging around the stacked imbalance
chances are it's gonna fail so I got a
lot of bearish stuff in here
you know divergence divergence Delta
scalper stacked imbalance divergence and
ratio I'm all excited
let's get short what happens nothing
market just goes sideways that's your
clue that's your cue to get out of the
trade you know don't let the market come
up here to sixty-seven and it happened
and that's where you get out and all if
by the
fourth bar fifth bar definitely if
you're still in it get out you know the
move should have happened already it's
not happening so we do start making new
highs got a ratio and divergence so you
know you're looking up here and honestly
you're thinking like I failed that
merchants failed divergence failed
divergence and a ratio when it comes
right back up with a bullish ratio right
so again you got this divergence you got
the bearish ratio but what happens the
market comes right back with a bullish
ratio that's not a good sign that this
is gonna sell off and you start coming
here and make a new high you got another
divergence so you made a new high yeah
great you made a new high by what is
that three ticks and what are you
looking at now you got your new high you
get out you have one control up near the
top you got it nice strong negative
Delta thousand next bar is actually up
it's a green bar negative Delta is 62
but you get here
stacks selling a balance you know you
got a zero print as well which is
bearish next bar you come in here you've
got a bullish ratio which is a terrible
sign to get right after you got a
stacked imbalance what you want is you
don't want this bar what you want is
this bar right here with the bearish
ratio and you know you get a little bit
of a sell-off and you start seeing you
know you're coming into the cash open
it's right here at 8:30 actually you've
seen some selling imbalances 1 2 1 2 3
you come down in here you got the
starting price rejection giving you the
buy you're looking again positive deltas
now you're getting buying imbalances no
longer do you have the aggressive
selling and said you got some aggressive
buying coming in ok so you know so you
know did this work not really you know
you got a little bit of a sell-off it's
not the greatest move from this stack
selling imbalance you know it's maybe a
point to get out of it before you start
realizing that we're coming back up then
here you get this I'll say swing high
you get within two points of the high
two ticks rather the high and then
you've got Delta scalper again you got
the bearish ratio you know ideally you'd
like to have you know there's maybe
point of control at the top or something
a little bit something else but again
you know you have a sell signal up near
the high of the day you know it's not
right on the high of the day
but it's close enough to the higher that
you're talking about a point away from
the high of the day that's good enough
you know just as you'd be looking at
taking this cell signal here the stack
get balanced here you got the Delta
scalper giving you a cell right here and
what happens is he starts selling off
selling off boom boom boom selling off
you know this is what levels that sixty
six and a half you start selling off
selling off selling off come all the way
down here get within a couple of ticks
that alone get down to sixty and a half
so you went from sixty six and a half
down to sixty and a half you know even
if you're covering it up here at 62 and
a half you know maybe you're thinking oh
we just bounced up but again look at
this Delta it's still negative Delta all
negative Delta you do have some support
of buying in here with this three 497
even the next bar 26 94 2392 you know
but again you know you see in this
buying coming in you should be thinking
are we going to go up or not
you know that's supportive you think the
market should rally back up but again
it's it's been a quiet day for the most
part in in the SPS and you know this is
your opening price this this line here
and in the markets that are
directionless you often will just hang
around your opening price and what
happens we will come down to the low
down here we hit the low trading 157
okay what happens we bounce we rally
back up to that yellow line you got the
bearish ratio you sell off again boom
you hit the low again 60 Lots this time
now this you know I'm I like it when you
retesting lows I'm always interested in
that so first time you hit that low at
257 yet 107 you know but now the cash is
open you hit it you got 157 at 913 again
at this point I'm not really looking at
what the what happened at 2:00 in the
morning you know with order flow you
don't really need to spend a lot of time
on you know all this stuff to the to the
left
you know you mean yeah you got to look
to the left a little bit but you don't
have to go back to 2:00 in the morning I
mean you can like here I'm just curious
you know what the volume was at this
time was 107
here's 157 so that's a little bit that
mean it's 50% more you know but it's
still around the same level but then you
hit that low you got the price rejector
give
you buy signal you've got less volume so
you got sixty Lots traded against 157
the first time which again is also a
bullish sign any what happens is you
start rallying at this point honestly
I'm just looking for this market to sort
of come back up here to you know hang
around you know hit the maybe the 63 in
a quarter area and sell off again what
do you do is your rally back up here and
you can see the aggressive selling
coming in here 3 3 5 20 101 but then it
comes back here with some nice
aggressive buying 400 400 800 and you
really put in a decent rally all the way
up to the 66 67 area up in here you're
starting to see some bearish embarrass
ratio here again you got 398 same level
32 so you got less volume Delta scalper
giving you a sell right in here so you
got the swing high you know your high
for the day is up here at 68 and 3/4 and
this is 67 you know I wanna say it's
close so you're talking about two points
away but it's it's a swing high alright
and you're getting some bearish signs in
here you know even if it's the swing
high I would still treat it as if it was
you know a high of the day and you know
at this point you're looking at it and
you got you know some bearish signs in
here then you got the Delta scalper you
know here you got the ratio you got less
volume
you've got the Delta scalper giving you
a cell and you know as far as I'm
concerned it's it's a selling
opportunity you know easily you know
imagine if this was the height of the
day right here at 67 and a quarter you'd
be looking at it I'd be looking at it
and making the same analysis you know I
treat swing highs you know what I look
for at highs of the day I also look at
swing highs what I looking for at lows
of the day I also look at swing lows and
what happens is so I know that for
sell-off you know my target immediate
target is going to be this this yellow
line because again I'd be looking for
the market to sort of hang around there
trade down towards it and maybe go there
for you know a while and just sort of
hang around rotate around it so you get
down to it and you keep going you keep
going you don't immediately come down to
the low but look you just sort of
hanging around here you know what time
is it no it's 11 was 11:30 you just sort
of hang it around that level so again
I'm not saying you
short here and you cover it down here no
honestly I'll be looking to cover it
somewhere you know just below this 63 in
a corner you know maybe sixty three
sixty two and a half so yeah that's a
nice four-point move there now the last
mark I'll talk about is crude oil Texas
tea let me just go back a bit here let
me just find my chart and sure it is so
again you know crude oil this morning
right off the low you got this low here
look at this Delta minus 557 is the min
Delta in this bar ends up at 35 its
market starts trading higher you get the
market turning around so very strong
sellers early in the bar and then the
bar essentially after you get to that
that low point you know with all the all
the selling and the buying comes in so
you know the selling the words that
happened to the selling it's not there
anymore right instead you're seeing
aggressive buying and that's the beauty
of it it's hidden in there it's hidden
in the Delta that's why you have to get
you should really pay attention to the
maximun Delta not just the final Delta
next bar Delta scalper giving you a nice
buy signal and was the dude goes up from
you know the 76 area all the way up into
the 90s about 4900 actually it gets up
to but you know really 4994 somewhere in
here he's starting to see the red
candles and you know what does this mark
the new it's just sort of goes sideways
on you you know honestly I thought this
was a little bit bearish here but I
started going sideways then you know you
got this you poked up here you poked up
to the opening price again 49:14 and you
know you have this you have this area
here right this is the interesting part
so you got this sideways action and then
also in boom very aggressive buying
coming in and you see four imbalances in
this bar next bar you got stacked
imbalance and another two imbalances up
here then you get here he hit the
opening price this is the red line is
the price rejecter he still got positive
delta you're not going any higher you
know you got you looks like you're
breaking out of this range in here
alright so you're expecting the market
to really
make a move higher and it doesn't it
just hits that area rotates off of it
starts selling off you got the bearish
ratio here you know you got this couple
imbalances but again you know ask
yourself you should be asking you know
this is part of being a trader asking
what's going on in the market when you
have you know very bullish signals and
you got it here with nice positive
deltas and you know the the multiple
boatload of imbalances you're expecting
the market to go higher but something
has changed in the market you know from
from here to here I mean a cash opened
obviously this is 831 but you've seen a
shift right you're seeing a shift from
what look like you know demand in the
market is also now you're seeing supply
coming and 196 255 521 then you get down
here small Delta you know I don't I say
you went from 220 220 to minus 15 those
big swing not really honestly it's kind
of small I mean over you know was it
this one you know 557 235 that was a
strong one yeah about 200 215 is not
that strong now you get the Delta
scalper giving you a buy in here get in
some nice positive Delta does it really
rally not really kind of go sideways
then you start seeing some you know some
selling coming in here you know sideways
sideways sideways sideways side well
then you had this ten o'clock you know
you got some activity came in up you got
this stacked imbalance here and again
comes right back with a bullish ratio
that's not a good sign
you have stacks selling imbalance you
want a bearish ratio not a bullish ratio
else those are something I thought there
was something else I wanted to talk
about here so yeah so we started
rallying up in here again you know hi is
up here 4933 got back up to the opening
price 49:14 some nice mine coming in
here again you know I was rallying up
towards this opening price you know 400
700 500 a thousand a bunch of imbalances
in this bar and then here where's the
follow-through you know if there's no
follow-through buying
you know in the sense that you know I
use the term follow-through buying
really what I mean is you know other
buyers coming in and following in the
move you're not getting it instead
you're getting selling coming in you
know had positive Delta 300 ends up at
minus 105 so it's a swing of 400 the
next bar all negative Delta zero max
Delta min Delta minus 686 we close on
that number Delta scalper giving you a
cell and you know you make a push push
back down to this area where you got
this small Delta then you start rallying
back up again so you know that's it
basically this morning you know there
were some interesting things I don't
really want to get into too much but let
me just see if I get one other quick
chart here for you the decks this is the
Delta scalper on the dax a uni Renko
chart it's a great market index if
you're positioned correctly and a dax
it's a great market to trade so you know
you got some small wins here or small
ones here small win here a small win
here I guess you'd call it then boom I
mean even if you're in this trade from
here
you got another buy signal here I don't
know if you were taking this maybe
you're still long from here but yeah you
can you're talking from an area of 12 to
80 I'll weigh up to your cell signal up
here at 12 330 so that's a 50 point move
you know the cell fails got another cell
up here this one to me failed got some
buys it just goes sideways on you you
know you're not every trade is gonna be
a winner about you know if you're
risking you know five ticks on the each
of these trades yeah you just lost 15
ticks you know but you just had a fifty
tick winner and even before that you had
you know maybe you know another 30
points and profits you gotta sell here
didn't work out a cell here and then
work I got a small winner here again you
get another small winner here
loser losing trade is what I mean here
not calling you a loser then you get
nice another nice winner here you know
if
12 9 9 5 up to 320 you know so even 300
you know up to 320 you're talking it's
one another 20-point move it takes out
some of these losing trades another sell
here then again another buy here you
know what this is 12 3 3 10 you know
comes all the way up into this you know
thirties forties area you know before
the soft curves a little buy here and
little buy here a little buy here this
one fails you know and getting us some
nice moves here so yeah it's it's a
terrific market to trade with the Delta
scalper I also say you know let's take a
look at it so thanks for watching this
to learn more about the trading software
or a closed trader go to order flow is
calm and more information on the Delta
scalper go to Delta scalper calm so
thanks and have a great day
sorry guys I didn't have the trading
room open today I'm not sure what's
going on with that anymore but you know
I'll keep you guys posted you know it's
it's September it's actually kind of a
busy month for me it was presently but
but anyway guys you know I'm if there's
anything interesting happens in the
afternoon session I'll try to get a
video out in the evening time and
discuss discuss what when I see so have
a great rest of the trading day and I'll
try and speak to you later bye bye
you